in a statement on Monday jeff Sessions
said that he would not renew the
National Commission on forensic science
and this is according to the Washington
Post the the committee the National
Commission on forensic science is a
about a 30-member advisory panel of
scientists judges crime lab technicians
and leaders prosecutors defense lawyers
this was charted by the Obama
administration in 2013 the goal was to
strengthen quote strengthen and promote
scientific validity reduced
fragmentation and improve federal
coordination of forensic science the
best way for you to understand the
importance of this commission and why
Jeff Sessions not renewing it is such a
significant story you have to think back
to 2015 I don't I reported it I believe
David also reported it in 2015 there
were about 200 cases over a two-decade
period before 2000 where all of the
cases or at least ninety percent of
those cases were called into question
because of flawed and overstated
testimony this resulted in 32 defendants
the case is included rather 32
defendants who have been sentenced to
death and of those 14 of those 32 were
already executed this commission found
that the testimony was flawed the
Commission found that the expert toast
so-called expert testimony was
overstated and these cases led to the
death penalty for 32 peoples some who
are now still on the death bro but this
shows you that the science that has been
forwarded by the Department of Justice
and the forensic experts in testimony
they have not been effective and this
was only discovered by this commission
put together by President Obama that
Jeff Sessions is now undermining and
it's very important because a lot of
this forensic science didn't come around
until the 1990s there's a lot of people
that are on death row even today were
sentenced before that and you know the
evidence that was used to convict them
didn't include DNA evidence so yeah
looking back I think four percent of
people right now on death row are
actually innocent of all the things that
are should be important to the Attorney
General
is on the top of his list he feels that
attacking this panel this commission
this charged with reviewing forensic
testimony and experts is something
that's detrimental to the Department of
Justice I can't help that but recognize
the effect that this would have on on
anyone right but the disproportionate
effect it has on minorities and the
communities of color because of how we
are disproportionately represented in
the justice system so i have just of all
the things jeff Sessions could focus on
he feels that this is the top of his
list and I want you to hear really
quickly his double speed his 1984 styled
language he said the ability
availability a prompt and accurate
forensic science analysis to our law
enforcement officers and prosecutors is
critical to integrity of law enforcement
reducing violent crime and increasing
public safety we applaud the
professionalism of the National
Commission of forensic science and look
forward to building on the contribution
is made in this crucial field but he's
not going to renew it I mean this is
this is amazing doublespeak yeah because
the risk that they run is that a lot of
people on death row or even just locked
up for any other crime may be proven
innocent by these forensics and that's a
big embarrassment to the Justice
Department isn't it and it's a reason to
get rid of the death penalty and this is
a reason to get rid of the death penalty
but it also shows you that Jeff
Beauregard sessions is more interested
in maintaining the reputation of this
agency and of the Department of Justice
rather than actually carrying out
justice and this is the person that
Donald Trump feels it's best suited to
lead the department of justice today's
program is made possible in part by
gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8000
new and classic games for xbox one xbox
360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them
for a low used price never with due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a 30 day free trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30-day trial for
david pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at gamefly
offer.com /td PS